good question well you know I went to
Taiwan 30 years ago I didn't get to the
mainland but I I did live in Beijing in
1986 of 21 years ago I was living in
Beijing and I belonged to a Chinese work
unit when I was teaching at the Chinese
Academy of Social Sciences in Beijing
and you know even after 10 years of
reform you still had rationing you know
I had to get a ratio on racial coupon in
order to buy a bicycle and because I was
a foreign expert I kind of jumped the
queue and I had all the resentment of my
co-workers and you know I got a lot of
in a short time I got a lot of insight
into many of the problems with plan
systems and rationing and now if you go
back to Beijing it's just unbelievable
how open the economy is you know you can
just walk into an ordinary supermarket
by all kinds of recognizable brands from
around the world you can buy kellogg's
cereal you can buy Australian wine
cheaper than in the United States you
can buy a wide range of electronic
products you can go get an ipod nano
more or less the same price you pay in
the United States now some of that may
seem shallow and if you're a very rich
country you know you can sneer a little
bit availability of electronics and food
but if you're a poor country where in
living memory people were starving to
death it's quite a remarkable thing to
go into markets and have a wide range of
products you know to be able to buy food
to be able to buy imported goods this is
really tremendously improve the material
standing of people in China and I think
that's a key first stage of development
of economic development is just meeting
the basic material human needs I you
know I wouldn't want to exaggerate so it
is still a one-party system and the most
recent speeches of you know president
who Jintao make it clear that the
leadership envisages the continuation of
a one-party system for the foreseeable
future but there has been some political
change there's a much more open dialogue
about in many areas not in every area
but for a lot of economic and
environmental and social policy there's
a wide debate
the press and on University campuses on
television you know so I do a certain
amount of live TV where we argue about
environmental policies or social
policies so I think there's there's more
freedom to speak out about a range of
issues but not about every issue I think
there's more participation of ordinary
people at the local level you know so
you see lots of examples and in the
countryside you have some villages you
know where they're actually electing the
village head and probably more
importantly cases where people vote on
how to spend the small amount of village
budget that there is so you know they
have a little bit of money and people
vote on do you want to improve the road
into town or do you want to dig new
wells or do you want to improve the
school so I think that kind of
participation at a very local level is
important for getting good public
services and you definitely see that
kind of participation both in cities in
the countryside growing in China but all
within the context of a one-party system